Hubbard Oppenheimer led the Manhattan
Project and built the atomic bomb during
World War two David Cassidy's biography
as this week's public lives feature this
talk hosted by the New York Public
Library lasts an hour 20 minutes Thank
You Stephen
can you hear me yes it's a pleasure to
be here I'm really delighted to see all
of you this evening and I'm delighted to
have this recorded for the television
audience I hope it would not be too
boring watching the unblinking eye of TV
I this book is a biography of J Robert
Oppenheimer's it says and he was born
100 years ago this year actually on
April 22nd right here in New York City
on West 94th Street
he died 63 years later in 1967 in
Princeton as director of the Institute
for Advanced Study Oppenheimer is best
known today as the scientific director
of the Manhattan Project that built the
atomic bomb during World War two and as
a leading representative of American
science in the years following the war
then in 1954 during the McCarthy era he
was subjected to a personnel hearing
that resulted in the removal of his
security clearance and exile from
government for alleged red ties
communist connections but before then he
helped forge the powerful alliance of
American science with industry and
business a major theme of this library
and later with the military during World
War two
then enabled the nation to achieve the
dominant status in world affairs in both
science and international relations that
it still enjoys today America's rise to
prominence was so spectacular during the
20th century that it is often called the
American Century the hidden story of the
American century as Steven said is the
rise of American science and at the
heart of that story is J robert
Oppenheimer like all of this Oppenheimer
was shaped by his times
in addition he was a shaper of his times
for him this was so significant that I
began to realize as I wrote this book
but the full story of his life has to be
woven intimately into the story of the
nation and the century in which he lived
in a sense the book is a double
biography a biography of Oppenheimer and
a biography of the United States during
the past century before I proceed
perhaps I should say a little bit about
myself and how I got interested in
Oppenheimer and how I approached his
life now some of you may know me as the
author of uncertainty the life in
science of Werner Heisenberg Heisenberg
was the head of the German atomic
project during World War two
and originally I thought of calling this
book insecurity the life and science of
J robert Oppenheimer uncertainty and
insecurity certainly characterized our
times
well the Heisenberg book centered on the
dramatic controversy that still rages
over Heisenberg and his role in the
failure of German nuclear researchers to
achieve an atomic bomb or even a reactor
during World War two
having been concerned for many years
with the origins of the nuclear era I
turned my attention after Heisenberg to
the other side of this story so the
director of the wartime project that did
produce the atomic bomb opening the door
to the frightening horrors of the
nuclear age J robert Oppenheimer
although a great deal had been written
about Oppenheimer when I began and some
of the issues surrounding his life
entire books have been written about the
security clearance hearings the
Manhattan Project and other aspects of
his life there was still a lot to be
uncovered almost as everything about him
there was something more to be found and
in case in many cases a lot more in
addition no one had yet attempted to put
this all together into a coherent
account of the man and what he did and
why he did it it is now the first
full-scale biographical study of
Oppenheimer published in nearly two
decades in addition to its broad
comprehensive approach the book is
unique in another way it's the only work
to utilize all of the historical source
materials and documents on the
and as times that are now available and
over the past years many more documents
have become available especially during
the last decade
among the many new or previously
underutilized materials that I've
brought to bear on him include documents
pertaining to his family childhood and
schooling in New York City a lot of it
in the archives of New York City
archives and also at the ethical culture
society as the co-culture school they're
also recently Declassified records and
files held by the FBI including for
microfilm reels of his FBI security file
and the Atomic Energy Commission which
directed a nuclear policy up until the
founding of the Energy Department which
now has at that role then there are
archival records illuminating his
pre-war education and activities at
Harvard Berkeley Cal Tech and Gooding
and Germany where he studied and worked
and this is also among the first books
to utilize the important groups of
documents held at the National Archives
the Library of Congress and the former
Soviet KGB archives his papers were
donated by the family to the Library of
Congress and are open to public use
along with the papers of other people
like Isidor Rabi and of our Bush James
bryant conant a number of other key
figures in this story so this
comprehensive approach backed by the
vast array of documents and sources now
available has yielded important new and
fundamental insights regarding all
phases of his life and the center in
which he lived so in order to give you
an idea of some of the main issues and
themes in the book I thought I might
read some a few passages briefly from
several significant periods of his life
and the opening pages of the
introduction actually set the stage and
the perspective it went through about 50
drafts of this thing to get it right and
I like it still given another traffic
but it does pretty well it's put
everything into context and open it sets
the themes so we briefly from the first
couple of pages somewhat to edited the
story of J robert Oppenheimer is the
story of 20th century
America the trajectory of his life
closely followed the trajectory of
America's rise from a provincial
immigrant farming nation to the dominant
economic cultural and military power in
world affairs this occurred during a
century of world war political and
scientific revolutions and the
frightening horrors of totalitarianism
genocide and technological weapons of
mass destruction closely entwined with
both both stories was the advance of
American science including American
theoretical physics to world preeminence
as indicated by recent Nobel Prizes for
instance the startling practical success
of their work brought Oppenheimer and a
handful of others like him to national
prominence as statesmen of science at
the highest levels of government and
culture Oppenheimer was suddenly cast in
an entirely new role that demanded of
him the courage to confront and resolve
the difficult moral and ethical issues
raised at the dawn of the nuclear age as
did so many others of his generation
Oppenheimer who lived from 1904 to 1967
rose to fulfill the American dream that
had brought his elders to America during
the previous century but the dream
Harvard its nightmarish elements
Oppenheimer stories also the story of
the crises in Western liberalism and in
the moral obligations of science so
characteristic the political
entanglements and dilemmas of 20th
century scientists the United States
after World War two suddenly found
itself dependent or thought it was upon
a growing nuclear arsenal as the
cornerstone of American power and
protection and upon the formation of an
invasive national security state to
maintain it because of this Oppenheimer
and other scientist advisors found
themselves facing a personal dilemma
about the alternate ultimate nature of
their work and at the center of a clash
among competing scientific military and
political forces over the place of
science and scientists with an American
society the destructive consequences of
that clash owing apart to Oppenheimer's
own vulnerabilities are still felt today
while the Enigma of often himer remains
how did such an estate erudite
intellectual and abstract theorists
uninterested in the acquisition of power
become the leader of Americans
science the most powerful research
community in the world then having
become its leader how did he with all
his intellectual and social advantages
loses power so abruptly and as a
scientist company to be regarded by many
as unfulfilled if not a failure how
could a man of such high cultural and
ethical ideals a product of the best
education the nature the nation could
offer not only lead the project that
built and used the atomic bomb but also
continue to serve as a nation's foremost
authority on ever more powerful weapons
of mass destruction the answers to such
questions are contained within the
stories of both the man and a century a
century so dominated by America's rise
to world preeminence that it's often
called the American Century the term
American Century elicits for many the
myriad benefits of America's entry onto
the world stage yet for many during the
century and still today the term
American Century has also evoked another
meaning a meaning most fully articulated
by the influential publisher Henry are
loose the founder of the time-life
Empire and in his widely read editorial
essay titled the American Century this
essay appeared in Lucy's Life magazine
in February 1941 ten months before the
attack on Pearl Harbor as Americans
debated whether or not to enter the war
than raging in Europe the son of
American missionaries to China Luce
argued for America's entry into the war
with a mission to the world the nation
he said was already at war but it was
not a war for the destruction of foreign
dictators but for American global
influence we are not in a war to defend
American territory Luce declared we are
in a war to defend and even to promote
encourage and incite so-called
democratic principles throughout the
world the 20th century he explained is
America's first century is a dominant
power in the world but the nation had
had failed to assume leadership of the
world as he put it at the end of the
First World War now said Luce the nation
must quote accept wholeheartedly our
duty and our opportunity
most powerful and vital nation in the
world and in consequence to exert upon
the world the full impact of our
influence for such purposes as we see
fit by such means as we see fit
America's duty and mission were to
assume its rightful place as the world's
leader spreading the about the benefits
of American life around the globe
whether the globe wanted them or not
this made this mission greatly
contributed to the nation's
understanding of itself and its role in
the post-war era as the world entered
the Cold War the struggle driven by the
desire of both the American and Soviet
bloc's for world supremacy the United
States eventually emerged the victor as
the century it called its own near its
completion now as we enter the 21st
century the attacks of September 11th
2001 make clear that foreign opposition
continues to the Imperial vision of the
American Century at the same time the
world the nation's self-righteous
response to the attacks and has
continued its insistence upon pursuing
its own interests and military
adventures as we see fit indicate while
the American Century is doomed it will
not easily fade even as a new century
progresses Lucis model of the American
Century the pre-war preparation for
world dominance and the post-war
implementation provides a valuable
context in which to comprehend the
course of Oppenheimer's life which
nearly paralleled this his rise to
professional prominence during or before
and during the Second World War followed
by his sudden descent from the summit of
power
amid the Cold War drive for American
supremacy supported by the scientific
community so that in this in essence
sets the stage for this for the book
it's not what one reviewer is called a
fuzzy warm biography of the great man
but more an attempt to place him in the
context of his times and to draw some
lessons from it because he was so much a
part of his times now one thing I did
was I divided his life into roughly six
phases spread over 18 chapters and the
first phase may see a little bit about
each phase
a brief reading from each the first
phase includes his youth his family his
early education and the impact of World
War one upon him as he was graduating
high school
Oppenheimer as you may know was born
into a wealthy privileged upper-class
family in the city New York City his
elders were of Jewish descent and
stemmed from Western Germany they had
immigrated during the late 19th century
and like many others of that period they
sought immediate assimilation to
American culture giving up their
language their culture their background
their even their religion and attempting
to assimilate into the culture of the
United States I can sort of relate to
this my mother was a refugee of the
Armenian Genocide came to this country
in the 20s and her family too
immediately sought to assimilate no more
Armenian culture no more menial
languages that's all that old world were
Americans and I think that was part of
that generation that's that's what they
how they viewed themselves in their new
land now many of the issues that they
had to deal with the family of the deal
with were not only assimilation but also
their enormous wealth the father was a
textile importer and achieved great
wealth in the city and they were very
much interested in social reform and the
vehicle for the the Society for ethical
culture became their vehicle for
realizing their dreams and goals of
assimilation and right attitudes toward
wealth Oppenheimer attendee attended the
ethical culture school from 1911 to 1921
and there he was as interested in
literature and languages as in as much
as in science and math back more so
while I was writing the book I and
visiting ethical culture school the
archivist Serap informed me that someone
had found the papers in New England of a
English teacher that Oppenheimer had at
high school Mabel T Burnham and in her
papers she had preserved some of his
poems he happened to have tended in a
senior year of special class on verse
forms that she taught
and one of his poems the family not only
lived in the city but in their being
chauffeured around by uniformed
chauffeurs they were also taken to Bay
Shore Long Island where the family owned
a eight acre estate at went without with
the 25 room house five car garage horse
stables and Butler's maids and gardeners
to attend to all of the flowers plus
very sailboats on Great South Bay and a
March in March 18th 1921 miss Burnam
asked the class to write a poem in the
model of a French rondelle and she
recorded the best ones in her little
notebook that she had this little tiny
notebook and one of them was by Robert
Oppenheimer March 18th 1921 the sharp
salt breeze wafts up from the ocean
thoughts of the green of the Welling sea
and the gulls with their curious screech
of Glee give the sunset air such a home
of motion that there one may think of
some outworn
notion with more of love then there
ought to be for the sharp salt breeze
that wafts up from the ocean thoughts of
the green of the Welling sea there one
may drink of old Neptune's potion close
with soul to eternity oh there let me
stand though my spirit may flee to the
call that can bring such a weird emotion
the sharp salt breeze that wafts up from
the ocean thoughts of the green of the
welding sea
it's hard to believe that he was later
later the leading theoretical physicist
of the nation what's he writing poetry
for at this age and one of the points I
actually make is that he was falling
behind others of his generation of his
age of that time such as Heisenberg who
I compared him with often they were
focusing like a laser on their future
career as theoretical physicist studying
math doing physics not doing anything
having to do with literature or poetry
and Oppenheimer's all over the place
he's following all of his interests and
perhaps that's one reason he didn't
quite make it as the top physicist of
all times or
one who could was equal to Einstein or
Heisenberg never received the Nobel
Prize but he was still highly esteemed
by his colleagues another poem took a
more serious turn not to belabor the
point but that year was also the year
that the United States was undergoing a
great upheaval in the wake of World War
one there's a lot of social unrest
there was fear Bolshevik Revolution the
Red Scare and so on labor unions were
demonstrating and there were some
violence in New York City and there were
some also disillusioned in every nation
actually about the war and copying I
guess the poem or the form of the poem
of John McRae's famous verse on Flanders
Fields he wrote in another poem that was
untitled in Flanders Fields the Sun
sinks low and clouds flamed crimson with
its glow unnumbered crosses here we lie
while life and love go swirling by hours
have but God decreed it so he cannot
guide you where to go he cannot prompt
with yes or no the stage of life ours
was to die in Flanders Fields yet now we
see we have no foe nurtured by hatreds
that must grow it was we see the damning
lie and in a quaking voice we cry let us
have peace the Sun sinks low on flanders
fields robert oppenheimer it was really
for high school students it's it's
really remarkable poetry now in the
second phase of his life he then went on
to the ethical culture school was
practically a prep school for Harvard
and he went straight to Harvard after a
year of illness that he had to sit out
for one year and it didn't matter
actually because he was a year ahead to
begin with it was probably better for
him actually gained a little bit of
maturity it he again he was all over the
place intellectually at that time but he
did settle on physics he graduated summa
[ __ ] laude and chemistry
but decided by the end that he wanted to
go into physics he then went to
Cambridge University in England to study
theatre experimental physics and then
onto Gooding in Germany where he was
invited by the leader of the quantum
leading professor of quantum physics Max
Born who happen to also be Heisenberg's
one of Heisenberg's professors and he
decided to go then into theoretical
physics and got his doctorate with born
in 1927 he was then it was a period
after the war when American physicists
were attempting to build up American
physics into world leadership a part of
it was because of competition with the
Germans they wanted didn't like the idea
that Einstein and Heisenberg and all
these people were getting all of the
attention for making all these great
discoveries at the same time they wanted
just to build up science as a
precondition for American industry
business and military and part of their
strategy was to select certain bright
young people of small group and give
them fellowships provided by the
Rockefeller Foundation and then give
them the best education they could
possibly give them at a few universities
chosen to be elite universities
Oppenheimer was one of the 14 people
chosen the year he applied for this
he got postdoctoral grants from the
National Research Council which was
funded by the Rockefeller Foundation at
Harvard and Caltech and then he was sent
abroad to Leiden and Zurich where he
learned the new quantum mechanics at the
source during the late 20's returned to
the states in 1929 as professor of
theoretical physics at Berkeley in a
joint appointment with Caltech he was 26
years old at the time and he remained
there until 1947 when he transferred to
Princeton as director of the Institute
for Advanced Study except for two years
during the war at los alamos 43 to 45
and I happen to have a passage regarding
how this worked out at California at
Berkeley Berkeley was at that time of
bathwater of physics and
I never said he went there because he
wanted to do something with it he saw
there was an open blank slate and he
could build up a school for theoretical
physics it but when Oppenheimer arrived
in California the administrators of his
two institutions Caltech and Berkeley
were doing everything they could to push
their Institute's into the top ranks of
research in physics Berkeley by then
among the 20 or so institutions selected
by the NRC for transformation into elite
research centers was still far behind
its sister institution to the south
Caltech as the state university
hurriedly shifted its resources from
undergraduate teaching to graduate
research that expected his professors to
profess less and to research more
raiment Ebers the future physics Jarod
Berkeley was then in charge of
recruitment and he followed the same
strategy as his colleagues elsewhere in
gaining elite researchers for the
faculty the capture of NRC fellows who
by their very selection as fellows and
their performance demonstrated their
status as top prospects for future
appointments 1928 Burge successfully
coached 27 year-old Ernest o Lawrence as
NRC fellow universally regarded as a
prime candidate from Yale research to a
Berkeley position he'd promised his
catch not only immediate tenure and
associate professorship but minimal
teaching duties and lavish funding for
instruments Lawrence was the inventor of
the cyclotron for which he received the
Nobel Prize at the same time birds wrote
to Lawrence of his plans for a second
open position as you may know we are
gradually getting quite a strong
department and are constantly
strengthening it there are two positions
open for next year and besides that
being offered to you we will probably
try to get a really able mathematical
physicist of the productive kind for the
other position within 18 months or Burge
and elmer hall the titular chair of the
department we're so eager to have
another proven NRC fellow J robert
Oppenheimer for the open position that
they agreed to share him equally with
robert millikan at Caltech by 1930 the
berkeley physics department had pinned
its hopes on lawrence and Oppenheimer to
bring the university to the
top of American physics and I might say
the physics profession in the United
States had settled on them to bring
California physics to the top ranks
nationally and internationally and in a
way it was a preparation for Los Alamos
I was almost a precondition for the
success of Los Alamos that their
California school was in such a high
state of readiness now the next phase of
his life refers to the Manhattan Project
and he went from Berkeley to the
Manhattan Project he was selected as the
scientific head of the Manhattan Project
located it was the part of it located at
Los Alamos where the bombs were designed
construction constructed and the
decisions made to drop them on Japan so
much so much has been written about this
era this part of his life and the
definitive studies that have been
produced such as those by James Rhodes
the making of the atomic bomb as a
result of that I decided not to
reproduce what Rhodes did but to try to
grapple with some basic questions
involving this this whole development
especially regarding Oppenheimer and
others like him and I sort of set up
those questions in the opening page of
that chapter chapter 12 which is called
the organic necessity and this is a
quote from that organic necessities with
how Oppenheimer viewed the atomic bomb
is something unstoppable now I am become
death the destroyer of worlds
Oppenheimer exclaimed quoting the
bhagavad-gita as he watched in awe while
the world's first atomic bomb blast
stretched its firing hands into the
heavens from the New Mexico desert on
July 16 1945 three weeks later on August
6th a second nuclear explosion
obliterated over 60,000 lives and 68% of
the Japanese port city of Hiroshima
three days later on August 9th a third
bomb incinerated another 40,000 lives in
Nagasaki more than 100,000 people later
died of radiation poisoning on August 14
and sued for peace and unbunch of temper
second Japanese surrendered
unconditionally the world war was over
how did it happen that J robert
Oppenheimer the sensitive cultured
humanist so readily accepted his new
role as the scientific administrator of
and driving force behind the rapid
construction and ultimate use of the
atomic bomb how did so many others like
him join the effort these are problems
that have confronted scientists
historians in the general public ever
since the context of course must be
considered after all the world was at
war war in which the forces of Nazi and
fascist hatred were trampling most of
Europe and the Far East in addition the
nations Pacific Fleet had been almost
entirely destroyed in the surprise
attack on Pearl Harbor the feelings of
shock outrage fear and helplessness that
gripped the nation were not unlike those
felt in our own time in the wake of
September 11th the likewise led
immediately to war and even to overt
feelings of revenge but the world war
was a conventional war with armies
arrayed on both sides it was widely
considered by the Allies a just war even
though millions of lives were lost a
great many of them civilian lies
deliberately targeted in conventional
bombing campaigns although Japan was
close to suing for peace in 1945 the
atomic bombs that fell in Japanese
cities without warning brought the war
to a quick and decisive conclusion the
atomic the atomic bomb was recognized by
its makers from the very start is not
just another military advice but a
revolutionary new weapon representing a
quantum leap in destructive power and
imminent danger a single plane carrying
a single bomb could obliterate an entire
city moreover this was supposed to be
the civilized 20th century even after
the experiences of the civil war in
America and the First World War in
Europe the inhuman brutality of war and
conquest was still considered by many a
remnant of an earlier irrational unlight
'end era
despite the ready involvement of
scientists and engineers in previous
Wars scientists were still regarded by
many in the way that the ethical culture
society had perceived them I go into
this in an earlier chapter as agents of
human aspiration
operating on a higher moral level than
the providers of the destructive
instruments of war as a student of
nature and nature's laws the ideal
scientist represented by such men as
Albert Einstein and Niels Bohr was and
often still is supposed by the public
and by scientists themselves to embody
the highest values of all humanity and
its search for truth elegance and beauty
of nature because of this science was
supposed to transcend the petty
differences of nationalism conquest and
greed that foster militarism and the
brutality of war the contrasting
conceptions of science sight science
primarily is the source of human
progress or is the source of new
instruments of war and the conflict they
engendered as the war progressed over
the role of the scientist in an 8 nation
in a permanent state of military
readiness resonated across the remainder
of the century and across the second
half of Oppenheimer's life the
historical questions this conflict
raised at the dawn of the nuclear age
are fundamental what forces could have
mobilized and sustained the
determination of so many of the world's
best and most cultured scientists and
engineers in the single-minded purpose
of creating and using nuclear weapons
how did the new and permanent
relationship that this represented
between science and the military in
America evolved during the course of the
war and how did the consummate outsider
the awkward neurotic leftist humanist
and abstract theorist J robert
Oppenheimer become the driving force and
dominant intellectual and administrative
figure inside one of the most successful
and frightening military research and
development efforts of all time and I
try to go into all of those issues which
are deep questions and I'm sure more to
be said as well now after the war I
should say I also go into the decision
to drop the atomic bomb Oppenheimer was
the lead advisor on this and the chair
of the committee's that decided these
these issues and how he was how he
decided that why he decided it that way
and what he felt about it afterwards
topics I discuss in the book now
following the war of course was the Cold
War era and the first during the first
decade of it from 45 to 54 it was a
period of integration of science into
the life of a nation eager to gain world
influence in competition with the
Soviets thus the nation was at a
permanent war footing throughout this
era the economy was on a permanent war
footing there was a permanent draft and
so on as some of you may know recall and
there was also the rise of the
instrumental view of science that I
spoke about in in the book in the
passage I just read which is often be
called scientific militarism and it was
the rise of Oppenheimer and scientists
like him to national prominence in
influence on science and it's
applications they became what has been
called state scientists almost the court
scientists I guess in the European
tradition advisors to the power of
Centers of American culture and politics
and he was for the public and icon of
physics and I opened that chapter with a
brief statement here is chapter 14 icon
of physics physics physicists emerged
from World War two confident optimistic
popular and rich physics it was argued
had produced the weapon that had won the
war it now promised untold benefits for
American culture economy and world
leadership as the nation fulfilled its
self-appointed destiny to fashion the
American Century
overnight physicists especially nuclear
physicists became folk heroes reporters
clamor for their words of wisdom and
most cocktail parties were considered
incomplete without a great physicist the
public image of the physicist as
unworldly and incomprehensible suddenly
took on a new character
Oppenheimer the director of the secret
laboratory that built the bomb became in
the words of Philip brief a symbol of
the new status of science in American
society his thin handsome face and
figure replaced Einsteins as the public
image of genius
but even more the high quality almost
larger-than-life portraits of the
confident impeccably attired business
like Oppenheimer that graced the covers
of Henry Lucis time and life magazines
and an admiring article in The New York
Times magazine made Oppenheimer into an
icon of the emerging American Century
as such they reassured the public that
the scientists who had won the war by
building the most fearsome weapon weapon
ever unleashed on humankind were now
trusted partners with generals and
industrialists as members of the
American power elite the control of
those of these horrific weapons was in
the confident and capable hands of the
worldly-wise Atomic Scientists and their
urbane leader dr. J robert Oppenheimer
and I discuss all of his work on various
committees he was at the top ranks of
all advisory committees in this period
Atomic Energy Commission he was head of
the chairman of the general Advisory
Committee to the Atomic Energy
Commission which advised on the use and
building of nuclear weapons he was also
involved in the UN disarmament
negotiations and the formulating of the
Baruch plan for international control of
atomic energy actually the United States
was the only nation that had atomic
energy at that time but they were
worried that the Soviet Union was
rapidly getting its atomic bomb and
working as hard as it could on an atomic
bomb and with the help of spies from the
Manhattan Project and also their own
scientists work they did get one in 1949
which caused untold problems as what
you'll see in a moment but Oppenheimer
was the most inside the government is
one could get a truly a state scientist
if there ever was one and again it's
it's a role that he took on that if you
look back over his life it seems to be a
succession of roles he's the in
government insider the head of an atomic
bomb project administrator of this big
project Berkeley professor radical
leftist he had close associations with
the Communist Party in Berkeley the
theoretical physicists working alone in
his office and the ethical culture
student writing poetry now at one of the
biggest decisions that the general
advisory committee of the Atomic Energy
Commission had to render was what how
should the nation respond to the Soviet
atomic bomb which was revealed to the
world by Truman in September 1949 many
of the military leaders and a few
scientists who encouraged them said that
the nation should now go to the next
stage of nuclear weaponry and build the
hydrogen bomb which they call the super
and this was a bomb there was many times
more powerful at least at least a
thousand times more powerful than atomic
bombs in fact their unlimited of
unlimited power it just depends on the
amount of deuterium and tritium and so
on that you put into the thing
unfortunately no one knew how to build
one of these things but nevertheless we
got to have one well Oppenheimer and the
general advisor by zuri committee were
commissioned by the head of the Atomic
Energy Commission
David lilienthal to look into the matter
and to advise the government on what
should be done and Lilienthal said in
the broadest possible terms which meant
policy considerations as well and after
debates back and forth and in addition
to the lobbying of a group of rather
hawkish nuclear physicists among them
teller Edward Teller Ernest Lawrence and
some chemists at Berkeley Pitzer and I
can't remember the other guy number of
others that were in Seaborg was not
involved in that he was happened to be
in Sweden
that's how fortunately for him but the
tenth the the fear and the anxiety that
these people felt I tried to capture
that a little bit why would these people
suddenly want this hydrogen bomb and it
was clearly fear that the Soviet Union
if ever got that hydrogen bomb ahead of
us they would just immediately destroy
us
it was a fear that slick linked to Pearl
Harbor and similar to September 11th the
constant theme throughout is we do not
want another Pearl Harbor another sneak
attack and today are one of our great
fears is we don't want another September
11th happening in this country
it's amazing how fear can really drive
people to do things and one of the most
rabid people for it was one of the
members of the Atomic Energy Commission
Lois straws
I pronounce his name straws from he was
on the south he pronounced it that way
but it's spelled Strauss any case here's
a the committee met at the end of
October and after receiving a report
from Dave and Lilienthal they decided on
their recommendation what should be done
the committee drafted its report on the
same day October 30th 1949 in the
polarized atmosphere it was in the words
of McGeorge Bundy a polarized and
polarizing document in response to
lilienthal's request regarding advice on
the common defense and security on a
broad as on as broad a possible planet
his words turned out quite right on his
broad a basis as possible that's quoting
from lilienthal's letter to Oppenheimer
the head of the general Advisory
Committee the eight members of the GAC
present Oppenheimer Conant Robbie Fermi
Lee do bridge who is head of Caltech
Hartley Rowe Cyril Smith and Oliver
Buckley the president of Bell Labs Nick
Hartley Roe is the president of United
Fruit Company they decided unanimously
against a crash program to build the
super it was called the super because it
was so super big their decision rested
as much on broad military and moral
considerations as on narrow technical
issues in an appendix a majority of six
including Oppenheimer went further
holding that the super program itself
should not be undertaken they said no
one on the committee was convinced that
the Russians would soon have such a
weapon
weapon what if the current US design
would ever work or that the inevitable
widespread destruction of civilian life
entailed in the bombs use would be of
any great military advantage although
Oppenheimer's accusers later claimed
that he unduly influenced the Committee
on the moral issue Co Nance biographer
argues that actually was under Conan's
guidance that all of the members present
came to the following conclusion and
this was written by often himer he wrote
all the committee recommendations quote
it is clear that the use of this weapon
would bring about the destruction of
innumerable human lives it is not a
weapon which can be used exclusively for
the destruction of materiel
installations of military or even semi
military purposes it's used therefore
carries much further than the atomic
bomb itself the policy of exterminating
civilian populations we all hope wrote
often heimer for the committee that by
one means or another the development of
these weapons can be avoided we are all
agreed that it would be wrong at the
present moment to commit ourselves to an
all-out effort toward their development
instead as end quote instead they
recommended as previously quote an
intensification of efforts to make
atomic fission weapons for tactical
purposes and quote and from then on
Oppenheimer continually worked for a
spectrum of weapons in the United States
Arsenal including conventional weapons
tactical atomic weapons and a few
hydrogen bombs if they could possibly be
built a type of flexible response to any
military threat see here
but under the influence of teller
Lawrence straws and General Omar Bradley
Truman finally who Truman had not even
heard of this atomic bomb until a month
earlier but on January 30th 1950 Truman
ordered the development of the hydrogen
bomb now Oppenheimer's views on the
control of international control of
nuclear weapons flexible response and
the United Nations disarmament were
regarded as not acceptable to in many
circles he continued to work in those
directions however and he got himself
into trouble with the air force which
was then building up the Strategic Air
Command to drop the new hydrogen bombs
under general Curtis LeMay the air force
finally kicked him out as an advisor
after a name-calling incident in which
is reported anyway that Oppenheimer
called one of the generals at war monger
and the general called him a traitor
after that teller was their main advisor
interestingly or ironically uh
Oppenheimer then found welcomed warm
welcome in Eisenhower's unit two in the
army Eisenhower was then the supreme
Allied commander in Europe and he
welcomed tactical fission weapons to
defend against an invasion of Russian
troops Soviet troops from East from the
east in East Germany into West Germany
so if Mehta and Oppenheimer was a
favorite of Eisenhower
although Eisenhower was not able to
protect him later on when the going got
hot in political terms now I have a
quote here from
the period after after this as
Oppenheimer worked more for
international control nuclear
disarmament and fission weapons as part
of a flexible response including
hydrogen bombs that they could be built
it became more and more the target of a
campaign to get him out of office and he
had made himself vulnerable to this by
his past associations with communists
many members of his family were party
members of the Communist Party and I can
go into that some more but he was not no
one has yet shown that he was actually
himself a member of the Communist Party
now what was really happening was on a
broader scale a clash of the two views
of science that I discussed earlier in
one of those passages this view of
science and scientists as
representatives of human culture
attempting to advance our understanding
of nature and knowledge for the benefit
of humankind and the other vision of the
scientist as the technician working to
provide the government with the
resources it needed to wage war and to
build up its consumer economy those are
the two images and it's sort of an
instrumental versus a humanistic vision
Oppenheimer clearly represented the
humanistic vision and the clash of those
two ideas at the height of the of the
Cold War and during the fear that was
descending upon the country regarding
the possibility of imminent nuclear
warfare
resulted in his being selected as the
representative person to be driven out
of government in an attempt to control
the scientists essentially now he was
subjected then to a personnel security
hearing at the Atomic Energy Commission
after accusations were made that he had
lied about a previous spy attempt by a
approached by a colleague of his the
infamous Chevallier affair which
Oppenheimer completely mishandled and by
his continuing lack of enthusiasm for
hydrogen bombs made making him a traitor
possibly in a security heuristic at
least and during the testimony Edward
Teller proved the key witness against
him and the committee finally accepted
tellers view and here's a quote from the
excerpt from the hearing hearing itself
if you've seen this transcript was
published by the Government Printing
Office in record time two weeks it's
over a thousand pages of single space
tiny print and weighty through that was
quite a effort but there there's a new
addition out it's hits on the high
points but if you look at the actual
thing it leaves out some things though
that are important so here's what here's
what teller said in his official
testimony during the hearing teller in a
now widely read statement informed the
board that Oppenheimer was loyal but
that he regarded him as a security risk
because he could not understand his
actions and disagreed with him on the
issues tell her but I have always but
I've always assumed and I now assume
that he is loyal to the United States I
believe this and I shall believe it
until I see very conclusive proof to the
opposite Rob Rob was the prosecuting
attorney actually it was just a hearing
but it turned into a prosecution now a
question which is a corollary of that an
earlier question do you or do you not
believe that dr. Oppenheimer is a
security risk teller in a great number
of cases I've seen dr. Oppenheimer act I
understand dr. Oppenheimer acted in a
way which for me was exceedingly hard to
understand I thoroughly disagreed with
him on numerous issues and his actions
frankly appeared to me confused and
complicated to this extent I feel that I
would like to see the vital interests of
this country in hands which I understand
better and therefore trust more I would
feel personally more secure if public
matters would rest in other hands later
under direct questioning from Board
Chairman gray Teller made explicit that
to him Oppenheimer's advice did in fact
make him a security risk mr. gray I
would then like to ask you this question
do you feel that it would endanger the
and defense and security to grant
clearance dr. Oppenheimer the witness if
it is a question of wisdom and judgment
as demonstrated by actions since 1945
that is after Manhattan then I would say
one would be wiser not to grant
clearance that was enough for gray a May
27 1954 the personnel security board
rendered its decision by a two-to-one
vote the Board found that Oppenheimer is
a loyal citizen but that as teller has
suggested he was never nevertheless a
security risk gray and Morgan two
members of the board were in the
majority Ward the only scientist voted
in favor of clearance and here's an
excerpt from their finding we find his
conduct in the hydrogen bomb program
sufficiently disturbing as to raise a
doubt as to whether his future
participation if characterized by the
same attitudes and government program
relating to national defense would be
clearly consistent with the best
interests of security
the majority elaborated in the body of
their separate report on their chilling
views regarding Oppenheimer's attitudes
first they faulted him for insufficient
enthusiasm following the president's
decision he did not show the
enthusiastic support for the program
which might have been expected of the
chief atomic advisor to the government
under the circumstances then the
majority believed he was hiding his
undue influence on others even though
they had found him unduly susceptible to
influence it is our feeling that dr.
Oppenheimer's influence in the atomic
scientific circles with respect to the
hydrogen bomb was far greater than he
would have led this board to believe in
his testimony before the board finally
in the defining statement the board
majority found that Oppenheimer may have
transgressed what the board determined
to be the accepted boundaries for the
role and duties of the enthusiastic
scientific adviser beginning with an
apparent answer to Bush and Conant who
had testified in favor of Oppenheimer
majority stated we must make it clear
that we do not question dr.
Oppenheimer's right to opinions he held
with respect to the development of this
weapon we are concerned however the
DeMeo
departed his role as scientific advisor
to exercise highly persuasive influence
in matters in which his convictions were
not necessarily a reflection of
technical judgment and also not
necessarily related to the protection of
the strongest offensive military
interests of this country in evaluating
advice from a scientist which departs
from the arena of his specialty
government officials charged with the
military posture of our country must
also be certain that underlying any
advice is a genuine conviction that this
country cannot in the interests of
security have less than the strongest
possible offensive capabilities in a
time of national danger Oppenheimer and
scientists like them in other words were
to be seen but not heard this has been
more or less the official view of
science advisors ever since to the
United States government there to
provide mostly technical information and
to keep their opinions to themselves and
I said more or less I would say it's
more under the present administration
scientists we fast forward to 2004
scientists today is if you've been
seeing some of the articles in the paper
recently have been complaining a lot
about how the Bush administration has
failed to take into account many of
their views regarding the nature of what
should be researched how it should be
research and the results of what they
have found in politically sensitive
areas such as global warming stem-cell
research health policies and so on
recently in August 2004 John H Marburg
the third who was the science advisor to
President Bush stated in a is quoted
actually by the New York Times in
science section no one will know my
personal positions on issues as long as
I'm in this job I am here to make sure
that's that the science input the policy
making is sound that the executive
branch functions properly with respect
to its science and technology missions
in other words he supplies the science
they do with it what they want
Scientific American responded to this
not directly but in September 2004 last
month's issue in their editorial they
mentioned the complaints of scientists
being not not being permitted to comment
on the on science related policies such
as missile defense which is being
promoted strongly by the administration
of iron mental policies health care
policies the critics such as Marburger
say that science and politics should not
mix says Scientific American then quote
but Einstein knew that scientists have a
moral responsibility to explain their
work including its political
implications to argue otherwise is to
say that science just does not matter
and quote Oppenheimer was then exiled to
Princeton and before he died in 1967
there was an attempt to rehabilitate him
to some extent by giving him the Fermi
award in 1963 this is the nation's
highest honor for a nuclear scientist
teller had gotten the award the previous
year the ward was supposed to be award
was announced on November 22nd 1963 the
day Kennedy died Johnson then he was
supposed to give the award that that
couple days later Kennedy was opposed to
give it a couple days later Johnson then
came into power came into the presidency
and a week later Johnson converted on
Oppenheimer in a courageous move that
Oppenheimer recognized because Johnson
himself had not yet consolidated his
political basis in Congress and in the
nation and as it turned out half of the
Congress boycotted the ceremony
including the entire top of committee on
nuclear affairs of the Senate
Oppenheimer then died of cancer a throat
cancer he was a lifelong chain smoker
and pipe smoker and apparently he died
of that his family actually had a all
almost the entire family died in their
early sixties there's now no one was
actually Peter it's only the only one
surviving now is Peter his son he just
turned 63 the share same age Oppenheimer
was so
is so far got the record but along with
off and on now I like to close with a
quote from Oppenheimer from 1964
referring to free research the necessity
of free research in a speech in Toronto
actually that he gave our contribution
free research is our contribution to the
making of a world which is varied and
cherishes variety which is free and
cherishes freedom which is freely
changing to adapt to the inevitable
needs of change in the 20th century and
all centuries to come but a world which
with all its variety freedom and change
is a world without nation-states
armed for war and above all a world
without war Oppenheimer's belief that
the pursuit of knowledge unfettered by
bureaucrats can lead to a world without
the mass killing of modern warfare is a
hope both noble and necessary in these
troubled times thank you I'd like to
entertain questions thank you very much
thank you dr. Cassidy guessing thank you
very much how long did up in heimer
study and work in Germany he was he was
there from uh 20 C 26 to 27 in göttingen
he then came back he went back to the
states and then came back on a
international education board fellowship
in 28 to 29 not specifically to Germany
he was in Leiden and then Zurich with
Wolfgang Pauli and he met Robbie in
Leipzig where they attended lectures by
Heisenberg but he didn't really study
officially with Heisenberg there's
always a brief time and in the course of
things but long enough to get a sense of
what was going on there he did write
about it later on now so the subsequent
question is how how important would it
be for any physicist to come to this
country where else could they study
other than this country it's in that
period now and now yeah well there are
there are plenty of good textbooks out
there that people can use but if you
really want to do top-notch research
this country is still the best place to
go you have to learn it from the master
and with a group of people and most
research today is done in labs with
group research and research teams
working together it's very rare that a
lone genius works alone an isolated
place somewhere now a lot of good
research can be done in Germany now they
have very good equipment and there are
some good work coming out of many of the
Institute's there like the locks block
Institute for extraterrestrial physics
and the genetic Institute near Leipzig
is very good but this is this is still
the place although if current policies
continue for preventing foreigners to
come here and other centers get built up
in other nations it's it's easy to see
that the United States can decline as
other nations have declined in the past
such as Germany France England who had
their heyday at certain times and then
various political reasons and social
reasons declined over a very short time
very interesting talk thank you question
layer so lard as I understand it tried
to interrupt the use of the atomic bomb
by going to see Truman how did that
I mean Salar table viously know
Oppenheimer and vice-versa how did the
relationship continue after that I mean
I think so lard was absolutely right but
how yeah what what what transpired from
that meeting with Truman in terms of
Oppenheim it went nowhere in fact it was
part of a movement among Chicago
scientists
essentially to take a step back and
think how should we proceed with this
how should we drop this bomb under what
conditions and and what international
controls or discussion should there be
and they were worried about the post-war
situation with dissing result in
immediate arms race but everyone want
these atomic bombs how would the United
States look if it dropped these bombs
without warning and you know the whole
question of just you know what do we
want how do we want to proceed this is a
dangerous situation right now
Chicago scientists were very much
involved with that and they became very
active in the post-war period and salade
is one of the leading figures in this he
was kept a lot out of a lot of the
research by general groves general
groves attempt attempted to sorry
general groves attempted to keep him you
stand back here it attempted to isolate
him in fact he wanted him in prison the
alien imprisoned for the duration of the
war Oppenheimer was too lard also there
was an incident where Salar tried to get
a petition from the Chicago scientists
to Oppenheimer to distribute at the at
Los Alamos Oppenheimer the first attempt
often Oppenheimer intercepted it and it
went nowhere second attempts allowed
called upon his countryman teller former
countrymen from Hungary to bring it to
the attention of Oppenheimer
natella responded actually with an
argument that Oppenheimer had made and a
couple of other people have since made
in those years after that that it was
better to drop this bomb to show how bad
it was so that then everything would be
people would be so afraid of it that
they would do something about it doesn't
say well we got this ugly thing here but
no one would really take it seriously
and the argument was it's better to drop
it in order that the post-war world
would then seriously attempt to rid the
world of these weapons after that the
lard and Oppenheimer's far as I know had
nothing to with each other
do I have to go there oh yeah so did um
up and I'ma have a specific opinion on
the dropping of the second bomb three
days after the first and during his
career not with fellow scientists but
dealing with politicians army
industrialists do you think that
anti-semitism was a part of people
disliking him those are two good
questions he was on the committee uh
there was a committee set up by the War
Department
now the Defense Department that was a
it's called the interim committee which
actually served as the policy committee
for deciding the endgame with the
nuclear weapons and there was a
scientific advisory committee to this
political committee headed by
Oppenheimer and during May and June of
1945 Oppenheimer and his committee
looked at all the arguments for and
against the bomb and decided there was
no argument that would prevent them from
dropping the bomb without warning they
decided it was useless to try that and
in fact the decision was made on only
minor considerations of the objections
as far as I know the one of the reports
that was sent from the Chicago
scientists the franck report was
discussed by Lawrence during a lunch
break and by dessert they had decided
not to go along with that suggestion and
in the end Oppenheimer and the other
scientists all recommended using the
bomb and even said we have nothing to
say about political matters ours is a
purely technical function giving up the
whole store right there
then anti-semitism plays a role
throughout Oppenheimer's life more
sometimes less than others at Harvard I
made the discovery that anti-semitism
was really strong and it was affected
his studies actually he and a couple of
his colleagues were sort of Outsiders in
the entire affair entire university
actually the president of the university
was part of the immigration restriction
League was trying to stop immigrants he
was also the chair of the committee that
convicted Sacco and Vanzetti in Boston
and he came out with some very
anti-semitic mark remarks on the front
page of the New York Times rate when
Oppenheimer was coming during the months
before he entered Harvard as a freshman
so that throughout his throughout that
part of his career he was completely he
and his colleagues were actually were
inclined to a very closed existence
anyway they were very much interested in
intellectual cultural matters and they
were also being excluded from all the
clubs and everything they just sort of
gravitated together and they graduated
in three years and got out of there as
far as the later years I've tried to
look at what the situation was in
California the story of refugees in the
United States during the Hitler regime
in the 30s as a sad story most
universities would not accept them the
reason was it was a Depression era and
they wanted to give jobs to their own
students and they were cutbacks and
budgets and everything but they wouldn't
even take people who where they had
opportunities and a Cal Tech Milliken
who was the president of Cal Tech also a
physicist was prone to a few
anti-semitic inclinations in some of his
remarks as far as post-war many of the
many of the people who were or not I
guess a good number of the people who
were against Oppenheimer were also of
Jewish origin
such as teller or straws tell her I've
looked at each of these cases of why
they were against Oppenheimer and had
certain personal reasons
teller first of all had left Hungary as
a youth in the wake of the Communist
revolution in Hungary after World War
one so he was rapidly anti-communist
then he was very hurt that Oppenheimer
had not chosen him to head the theory
section at Los Alamos it picked Hans
bethe instead man up and I was very hurt
at that then he then when Oppenheimer
opposed to hydrogen bomb he was even
more hurt because that was his pet
project as far as Strauss was concerned
I discovered that he happened to be the
head of a head of temple Emmanuel in
unit in New York City there when he was
a banker in New York City during the
late 30s and early 40s and the ethical
culture Society has was actually sprung
had actually sprung from Temple Emanuel
1870s and Teller regarded it as
heretical and as a disgrace to Jewish
heritage Australis team Strauss Strauss
regarded as a disgrace because we felt
that everyone should pull together and
defend Judaism in the world with Hitler
out there and when he found out that
Oppenheimer and his family were steeped
in ethical culture he thought he was
immoral basically then there are few
incidents that Oppenheimer loud himself
to be involved in that tended to support
that as well but those are some of the
factors that went into it with very
theoretical question do you think they
ever would have dropped the atomic bomb
in Germany you do
the bomb was ostensibly developed to
drop on Germany and actually they were
going to drop it on anyone left standing
by the end of the war by that period
1945 the only nation left was Japan but
if Germany was still fighting they would
have dropped it and groves
in fact the decision to drop the bomb
and drop it on Nagasaki and Hiroshima
those decisions had already been made by
groves and the higher authorities
civilian authorities actually Bush and
Conant had already decided we're going
to drop this thing if we ever get it no
matter what it was the plan was to work
as hard as fast as possible and to drop
it before the warhead hit so they could
show the world that we have this thing I
want to ask you a question about power
obviously Oppenheimer rose up and had a
certain amount of power cut there
because of his intellect study
brilliance right but the way that he got
there was you just mentioned the
Rockefeller Foundation okay and
government now how do you divorce you
know government when you give over funds
do you say well you know you bring about
something and there are limits
obviously he put together this great
project that produced as you're
rightfully said the atomic bomb he
wasn't going to make the decision to
drop the atomic bomb right government
was so how do you bounce this you know
can he just be in a isolated area just
talking to himself making experiments
and not producing something that then
other people will make decisions about
I mean his hands weren't right it wasn't
a saint he was someone who
was a scientist yeah exactly this is
what this is partly what Oppenheimer
meant by the fact calling the atomic
bomb the and organic necessity when
Oppenheimer then after the war when he
expressed his guilt to Truman that even
went into Truman's offices and said he
his hands have blood on them
Truman said get this guy out of here I'm
the one who decided who to drop that
bomb he did not decide that but the
scientists still have a roll and they
still have a place and maybe that they
don't have the power the Truman has but
they can they know that what they're
building and they know that what it can
do and if they know that it's going to
cause a certain amount of harm or have
negative impacts that we don't want they
should at least bring those things out
to the authorities so that so those will
be known but not to follow orders and
just produce the thing and and that's
what they tried to do when the hydrogen
bomb came along they had a better
attempt didn't try they made a stronger
attempt at that than they did with the
atomic bomb but by then the game was
over they had lost they'd lost control
of it by then and the authorities were
much more powerful than the scientists
could ever have been but you know it's
there is this balance I mean you can use
science for good or evil just knowledge
we learn about the nucleus and forces in
it Einstein developed that equation e
equals MC squared which then leads to
the transformation of mass into energy
and there are those who could use it for
this purpose or not but those who are
using it for those kinds of purposes and
doesn't necessarily be war it could be
some other type of negative impact on
people or environmental impacts or
health impacts it's the obligation of
the scientists to at least represent the
human desire to to have a world that is
beneficial or have science be beneficial
to them in some way and to represent the
aspirations of humankind even if it
doesn't get anywhere but he did try that
with the hydrogen bomb
that's what I really admire about him
that he he'd put herself and put us out
himself on the line at that point and it
took a lot of courage to do that in that
in that polarized atmosphere in that
fearful atmosphere and he suffered the
consequences for him I think there's a
gentleman back there or I just want to
know maybe this stupid question but if
my mom was at Princeton did he do any
important research in physics yes he was
one of the things he did was he was the
scientific head of the Shelter Island
conferences that started in 1947 to
about 1950 where physicists gathered
together a small group of them funded by
the National Academy of Sciences
Sciences on Shelter Island and a couple
of other places in New York State and
what they wanted to do is overcome
hindrances to the advance of high-energy
particle physics there are some
theoretical problems infinities that
were appearing in equations and they
wanted to overcome those and during that
conference Richard Fineman and Eugene P
Vigna and Freeman Dyson and a couple of
others under the overall administrative
lead of Oppenheimer we're able to
overcome that and build an allowed
American physicists in high-energy
physics to just take the ball and run
with it and they're still leading to
this day he himself did not produce as
much actual physics in that period he
was attuned with it he was up with it he
went the conferences and talked with
people and commented on their work he
had a vast array of expertise in all
areas of physics experimental nuclear
high-energy theoretical work and he was
up with the literature but his main
contribution actually to physics was the
prediction of black holes in
astrophysics and 1930s but he
immediately dropped it
he just for at that point in his life he
was very much flipping around from place
to place in intellectual endeavors and
the community scientific community was
not ready for it at that point it wasn't
until 1990s that the Hubble Space
Telescope actually gave us some evidence
of black holes for which if he was still
alive you probably get the Nobel Prize
who knows okay so he never got the Nobel
Prize and his students in a school of
theoretical physics are there's whole
chapter on that my book on their work
there he was training them in the top
methods in theoretical physics but the
problem was theoretical physics and
high-energy physics and nuclear physics
at that time were hindered by these
infinities so they couldn't make the
real breakthroughs until after the war
but they were he was least training them
to them prepare them for their future
careers so many of the members of his
school went on to lustrous careers in
physics but at Princeton one fellow I
talked to said I met Oppenheimer he's
told me at the Institute for Advanced
Study I went to a conference and it was
very much up with what was going on but
he was not pushing the forefront anymore
but he knew exactly what was going on
even the young guy would come up and
have new string theory or something like
that because in those days they didn't
have that but they would then he knew
exactly what the guy was talking where
she was ahead of his time just like
Einstein doesn't have this time for
uniform yeah period right right
especially with black walls he was way
ahead of his time
what about his family life because you
know it's not like you go to a
nine-to-five job you know and you come
home and you have time to relax with
your family he had a very heavy job and
could he just sort of put that aside
when he you know had his family life and
also you mentioned about that he was
going to get that award in November of
63 was that going to take place in Texas
since Kennedy was already in Texas was
that going to be presented to him then
the water was going to be presented in
Washington with all the Washington
dignitaries there when Kennedy got back
and then Johnson made a decision he
could have handed it off to somebody but
he made the decision to do it himself
and give him the prize his family life
actually he wasn't married to 1941 and
he married Catherine Pugh nning dalit
who was the widow of a fighter in the
Spanish Civil War her husband had been a
a prominent member of the Communist
Party and gone over to spin to fight in
Spain and was killed and she had been a
member of the party but she left at that
point he had two children one the first
one was Peter born in 1940 about seven
exactly seven months later after her
marriage and he went on to I'm not sure
where he went to college but he's now a
carpenter in Santa Fe and he lives in
the family estate where they the family
cabin at cowls New Mexico where
Oppenheimer is a as a youth at a cabin
there and often went there to ride and
camp out in the countryside his daughter
was born Tony they called her Tony she
was real names Catherine in 1944 Los
Alamos that kitty was his wife's
nickname she like many of the wives at
Los Alamos was completely out of her
element and felt completely neglected
here are all these
Morton scientists doing their important
work over in the lab and their highly
educated women sitting home and they
would try to find things to do like they
found that a library daycare center
there was a baby boom as well so almost
sure and they definitely needed a
daycare center but Kitty was also
involved in a circle of friends that
tended to drinking parties in the
mornings when no one was around and she
became alcoholic after that had a lot of
problems
she she also died at the age she died at
the age of 62 1971 as far as I know the
home life must have been all right at
olden Manor and Princeton again it was
in a big estate with the the director of
the Institute for Advanced Studies put
into this was given this mansion there's
like it's 12 rooms or 12 karemera
exactly how many rooms and Tony had a
stable for her horse and the wife kitty
was a botanist so she had a greenhouse
put in and Peter wanted a photo
photography studio and then Oppenheimer
had his study rooms and things like that
and they had butlers and maids and so on
but I tend to think it was probably not
the warmest home life Tony later
committed suicide 77 the tragedy of the
family a simple one where is he buried
he was from New York City originally
yeah um he's buried at Princeton there
was a big big memorial service there all
the dignitaries from his life attended
teller and Strauss were not invited and
he was buried in Princeton
well that is about it for a time
my name is uh Steven morrow I'm from pry
press we are the proud publishers of
this book and I am for those of you who
would like to purchase a copy we have
books available back there you can see
Linda who will now raise her hand so you
know who she is
I want to thank you all for coming thank
dr. Cassidy David Cassidy is a professor
of science at Hofstra University J
robert Oppenheimer and the american
century is published by pi press for
more information visit their website at
pi press net next week on public lives
courting justice attorney David